but if you go and talk to like tea party
groups underlying this is really
concerned about their school districts
their property taxes the stuff you kind
of you can't really get away I'm Juna
Runga for reason TV i'm here with steve
malanga of the manhattan institute the
author of the new book shakedown what's
it about well it's about the evolution
over the last 40 years of what I call
the big government coalition the big
government coalition consists of public
sector unions and social advocacy groups
most of which live essentially off of
government funding and because of that
they are the chief advocates for bigger
spending in America for bigger
government in America not necessarily
because it does good but because it's in
their self-interest to always advocate
for bigger government why the social
advocacy groups and the union's
specifically why do I did you focus
specifically how the special intro they
are the main components of the
specialist they actually started
separately the social advocacy groups
were basically created in the 60s during
war on poverty when the architects of
the war on poverty believed that if we
spent enough money we could attack
poverty and government could sure
poverty it was well intentioned but
naive but one of the things they didn't
really know how to do this one of the
things they decided to do was financed
and fund a lot of local community groups
a lot of local programs and as a result
they essentially created thousands and
maybe I would say at this point tens of
thousands of groups that essentially
live off of government money and once
they created this constellation of
course it was in the self-interest of
these advocacy groups to go into
politics themselves and advocate for the
continuation of their programs for new
programs because that's what their
existence was based on how prepared of
the states to pay for these benefits not
at all we have three trillion dollars in
unfunded promises that we've made at the
state and local level to these employees
both for pension benefits and for
healthcare benefits it's really
unsustainable the state would go broke
if it had to essentially finance this
right out of its everyday tax ones what
you do is you
we's out all the other kind of spendings
you have to do spending on police
spending on teachers spending on
programs for the poor that just gets
squeezed out a little the money come
from eventually good question in some of
the worst states Illinois New Jersey
California there are experts who said
there's no way they will be able to pay
this bill and that they're going to need
some kind of a federal bailout now some
many argue that if there is a federal
bailout it could should come with very
strict restrictions it's going to be
controversial in any way but you could
easily say that in certain states it's
hard to predict where the money will
come New Jersey is a good example
they've been struggling to balance their
budget but even though they've been
balancing the budget they've been doing
it by skipping three billion dollars
that they need to be paying every year
into the pension system so even when
they figure out how to get their budget
straight in Jersey they still has to
find another three billion dollars a
year which is like fifteen percent more
tax revenues where's it going to come
from doesn't matter who's in office
Republicans Democrats or is it the same
story regardless I think in many states
it has been the same story the problem
is the taxpayers don't really have
either party advocating for them I call
both parties in some states the
incumbency party because what happens is
people get elected and then what they
most want to do is remain in power and
if they're threatened lets say by a
powerful special interest that could
unseat them they're more worried about
that than anything else taxpayers need
advocates they need to advocate for
themselves that's why you see the rise
of the Tea Party movement and if it I
don't know what it will accomplish but
what taxpayer groups really need to
start doing is find a way to be a
permanent presence themselves not just
sort of come and go when taxes get high
what is fermented the tea parties rise
at this point in time always the problem
guest now kind of boiled over so I
certainly think that what's happening at
the state local level fermented this and
then people began focusing on the
national level and that's core to
created a national moving but if you go
and talk to like tea party groups most
of them come out of like local taxpayers
association and they're very aware their
property taxes have been going
year after year their their income taxes
are going up that's already happened so
there they kind of like are focused on
that and then all of a sudden they see
this national movement and they go
online they sign on to it and now
they're also part of you know looking at
what's happening in Washington but if
you talk to them underlying this is
really concerned about their school
districts their property taxes the stuff
you cut it you can't really get away
from if the tea party candidates do well
in the upcoming elections there's a
signal the decline of this Union and
advocacy groups Alliance I don't think
one election signals that yet at all
because again a lot of these Tea Party
groups in general tax payer groups tend
to come and go they tend to be
grassroots efforts that come and go and
this coalition is there permanently so I
think that you need more long-term
structural change what kind of reforms
do you propose there's a lot of what I
call democratic reforms again in states
where that are heavily gerrymandered I
think we need to go to nonpartisan
redistricting like you're having states
like Iowa so that you don't have these
districts where you know half the state
is Democratic have two stages Republican
you can't defeat anybody in those
districts you know the other thing I
think you need to look at is there are a
lot of laws and rules like in some
states where when their contract
negotiations between unions and
politicians reach an impasse they go to
arbitrators in some states the
arbitrator's are told they're not
supposed to take into consideration
whether a local government can afford to
pay whatever they decide their reward is
well that's just crazy so is this really
a long-term kind of long-range direction
America facing and it's been it's very
difficult to turn the ship is that what
we what tense what tends to happen is
that the momentum is slowed down every
once in a while like the tax reform
movement of the 1919 70s tax reform
movement of the early 1990s where we saw
some of these states put in things like
taxpayer Bill of Rights so it happens
episodic ly periodic where the mention
is slowed down but but you know to to
actually say you're turning around the
ship I'm not quite sure we've seen that
yet well thank you very much Steve
Juna Runga for reason TV and thanks for
joining us